and thank you very much Beth inviting me
and first I would like to introduce to
structure their structure is me and my
husband Nathan before I started to say
anything about tariff structure how we
started and how we launched and how we
needed to change our path and what we
learned I want to start with the
conversation going on on linkedin and on
on the data science environment that we
say ninety percent of the world's data
created in last couple of years the
daytime I'm going to talk about this old
data but this is massive massive amount
of data and it is created in every
single university that you know of
anyways I will start to give you an idea
who I am oh and their terror structure
came from and the real heroes in this
journey that we took one is my husband
he was always there he was always
feeling the pain and my my pee is and
the angels actually missed it in this
company so I started my career 20 years
ago almost as a date-date data engineer
it was not called data science at all I
was developing algorithms for NATO
basically fingerprint recognition from
fingerprint recognitions the landmine
detection more exciting projects like
the flight stimulation aircraft modeling
as well as friend of friend or foe
or firing models so lasts two years of
my career in this in that company was
mainly on the business side I think some
of the business aspects i got from there
but when the money is not your money and
the investors were already investing on
that which was nato it is different to
be on the business side I learned it
much later when I was closer to my
thirties I decide I decided to change my
direction it was because i was told that
i have a brain tumor and it didn't take
too long for me to decide okay i'm going
to use all my data skills do you
understand what's going on in this
complex data because brain is one of the
most complex they data sets that you can
imagine you can look at the brain and
you can you can predict the behavior you
can look at the behavior you can tell us
stuff [ __ ] brain so it was so exciting
for me and I always loved the complex
data so in 2006 in 2004 going back it
didn't take too long for me to put my
backpack together and left Turkey which
is my country to the Netherlands there
are actually I met wonderful scientists
one of them is my PhD it by advisor dr.
avishai henick so I learned how brain
works how it looks what is the
psychology how you can stimulate the
brain using behavioral techniques
developing tasks or paradigms it was two
years later it was time for me to look
other directions because as I said my
interest was always data
the department i was in mainly on the
cognition and behavior am I my advisor
reagan came into play told me that there
is there is a unique center which was in
us and I never told myself being in us
until two thousand six so sure enough i
moved to us this is a very unique center
called complex systems and brain
sciences sciences they don't only teach
the brain but the complex days data for
example hurricane modeling predict
predictive analytics of the wind
directions and wavelength those models
so meanwhile i kept avishai as my
advisor I don't today I don't even know
whether it was a good idea but I started
to feel the pain when i was there
because i wish i was not next to me he
was not sitting next next to me he was
there in his we're in heist office in
his right i also had a very nice office
in florida and i could also walk to the
beach from from the school so the phones
and emails and skype messages fell short
i needed his attention as a Nobel Prize
winner professor he had more than enough
students to take to take care and work
work with ja I used to actually copy my
brain images on the word documents and
write what I am doing and then send it
to him sometimes I received messages
from him saying good or bad or most of
the cases nothing the professors are
very very busy if you are not in front
of them they will forget about too
easily and walking around the university
meeting new people
I I heard I heard a lot of horror
stories and I was happy that I was not
alone so I could relate my story's not
being able to graduate soon enough and
all kinds of stories hearing from
friends helped me a lot so my officemate
he was getting ready for graduation he
got a date to graduate but all of the
Sun and his professor asked them to go
and check his data or something else and
then he goes he checks his data is it
was not there somebody removed it
accidentally on the MRI MRI and server I
was said enough that he had to redo the
study and eight months later he
graduated and then another story that I
allowed to tell everybody is about the
server issues because there is a
professor I'm talking about two thousand
eight and two thousand nine this is the
time that everybody wanted to get grant
money everybody wanted to publish it is
still publish or perish so you get that
you get to do your research fast enough
you gotta have your data you the right
right and you need to get your money the
dr. breslar is one of them he was
working on monkey data and many look at
look at the u.s. u.s. is the heaven for
the monkey date data because of the IRB
rules and everything it was not strict
strict enough so he had terabytes of
data but his we didn't have bad luck in
Florida the wet labs he was working it
was in Montana so he was sending his
hard drives to Montana to get the data
and then he was using like Tom drives
and all kinds of different stuff he got
half a million dollar for his research
good enough he goes and buys couple
linux servers
but the do you think he has anybody to
take care of those unique service he's a
he's a psychologist with some
computational background he didn't have
anybody he put all those Linux servers
he was so happy he let his students to
put the date on it didn't take for
hackers to find out that he doesn't have
any security protocol running behind so
he lost all the data his his computer
was hacked his system was hacked but
though he had the happiest students
because he gave those servers is the PC
to his students so they had the powerful
computers to use their entire PhD so
spending time and money on algorithm
development is the biggest problem in
science nowadays because you don't
really have somebody to develop your
algorithms I mean there there is if you
are computationally saving you don't
want to start out stay in academia so
most of the people staying in academia
would be cheaper power everybody says
cheaper power but the people with the
computational background or who are
interested in this side of computers
they don't stay in academia so it takes
and hiring those people is not that
cheap so you spent a lot of money and
the other other issue there is Miss
placing and changing the data to most of
the cases the students put the computer
from one computer one data from one
computer to the other and they they
forget where they put the data at the
end of the day and sometimes they also
changed the nature of the data and they
are playing around even without knowing
they try to clean the data they lose a
reference point
it happens all the time and as I said
the server issues is the other problem I
mean there is there's no enough human
power to run the servers in the
universities there are a lot of crushing
virus issues everything is so slow and
the biggest problem not seeing the
actual data in a publication so you
collaborate with somebody in Israel like
my case my advisor never saw the actual
data in our publications if I iver
g.fast by my data he would be the victim
of my fascination because we are we we
we have names on the same publications I
mean two years ago this famous professor
his name is stopple he was a Dutch
professor he said that meat eaters are
barbarians because he figured that he
figured this with his surveys and
studies and he called data he collected
from people to 30 years later one
student one student figured out that he
was actually riding those surveys by
hands hundreds of surveys by hand and
changing the nature of the data he
collected he had to give back not on his
titles but his degree and the people who
wrote with him was the victims of his
crime so all those papers were withdrawn
all those people lost their jobs because
they didn't see the data they didn't
know what was going on out there
okay all those things for going along we
knew it we knew all those problems out
there and I was coming and crying to
this guy every day over six months
because these things change your life
and not being able to graduate I mean it
says I always call PhD is a
psychological battle and if you see all
those cases around you it really affects
you badly and he's the one telling me
okay if you have that much of data why
don't you put it on a cloud platform and
analyze it without starting and
interruptive Lee collaborate with your
remote coworkers it was good enough did
I listen to his suggestions yes but I
was so busy to get graduate leave
Florida Florida was wonderful but I mean
in if you are a PhD student you don't
really want to see anything you just
want to finish and start a new life and
make little more money become a postdoc
it's not a lot but a little bit more so
without me real we knew it we moved to
North Carolina it was and I was too too
busy to start my new lab and my my live
new lab was a little more exciting than
my former so I work with the infants and
it I was it was unbelievable ours and
schedule I was trying to get my
collaborators together get some new guys
at the same time my PhD advisor but my
postdoc advisor was trying to find a way
to build a platform together that he can
really reach out and collaborate with
them title I told him what we have been
thinking
and how we can leverage his data in his
collaborations and he said okay and we
we we started to brainstorm how we can
actually figure out this was my problem
this was my advisors problem and I heard
stories around me but we wanted to reach
out more people so we were we started to
discuss about the possibilities I went
to the business school we went to the
business school we started to develop a
story we wanted to know who our
customers for I thing for the startups
if you are starting for a niche company
the surveys are so important so you want
to know who your customers are what they
are using and what are they missing
these questions we gather together and
then sent out surveys and we figured
that these are some sort of survey
results and most of the customers in
this business use matlab and python is
very new to academia but they started
quickly started to adapt that and second
group of and the other group of
scientists a special python since it was
are started by a Dutch developer python
is more common in Europe was more common
in Europe then here's in lucky in
academia they didn't even know what
python is here but in in Europe they
started to use it pretty early so we got
a lot of positive responses about Python
being the part of this project
so as I said some people knew what it is
some people didn't know what it could be
so we had two different cost customers
one is the younger professors they are
more interested in computers they
understand how it works and the other
ones are the scientists who don't worry
about the analysis what is going on
behind the scenes but they want to say
okay this part of the brain took role of
this or that part of the brain did this
so they are more interested interested
in the findings again we identified four
big pain points that we wanted addressed
using my experiences my PA position in
this business and surveys results always
data gets misplaced and data get changed
money to spending time on money out
algorithms and being able to see did the
actual data before the publication is
going to give a bit relieved to the
professors and the server issues so they
come they can just store their data on
the cloud platform and now whenever they
need it they can share and collaborate
with their remote friends so here the
tower structure started it was going to
be a web-based platform as a service
terabyte scale of data processing
allowing the real-time collaboration if
you are if I am sitting here and you are
sitting in New York and it is if it is
very important to get together right now
you could get together you can get
together on this platform and the other
problem is that these are patient data
or data or participant data that you
don't want to share with people
who are not qualified or who did too
didn't find the security protocols for
IRB protocols for this this secure cloud
platform was so important to start with
it and also bigger the idea of who we
are dealing with we got these numbers
using the LinkedIn groups forms user
forms as well as friends and
collaborators and here with Julie we can
segue to our demo quickly and then I'll
tell a little bit more about the
business model Souter's as i mentioned
thirst structure is a web based
environment and here the data is
electroencephalogram data it was
collected in Holland and these are where
these patients are very rare this is
called dyscalculia and people some
people suffer from issues with number
processing so they look normal to you
but when you come with the numbers to
them like what is 2 2 plus 2 they will
become dyslexia a dyslexic or autistic
so this is the data collected from them
these are the different brain locations
of these people and here we are quickly
gonna plot a couple of electrode
locations this is basically for the
scientists to see what is the difference
what's going on in the brain and here we
used side side by tool boxes
just to start with and we are using a
method called principal component
analysis to analyze the data to this
point but we are not going to show it
here it's going to take sometimes we're
just going to show you how we label and
how the scientists can process and
interpret the data basically what he is
doing is that he is showing the center
parietal part of the brain and we are
going to look at the different patients
and different groups how it looks in
this plot and usually this is this is
the larger even you are working in a lab
you only have the opportunity to use met
MATLAB or EG lab and you're limited to
see different angles
and these this part of the screen keeps
your data and this is not this cannot be
changed by the users this can be changed
by the owner of the data whoever the
member for this platform these are
basically the codes that we used but
currently we only have numpy and this is
where you're going to see the flooding
right now and it is very simple for
people who really don't want to do don't
want to deal with any algorithm
development or don't wanna understand
what's going on behind it so here you
see two different this is the same part
of the brain activate it and these are
the two different numbers that they are
actually looking at and then these are
the two different plots that the brain
is responding to this is a very
important part for the professor or a
scientist because they will see that
something is happening around three
milliseconds after the process happened
and this is very clean date off how are
we going to go
okay okay after we had our first Minimum
Viable Product we also dreamt about this
opportunity we looked at the market size
how much money we can make and how much
we need to charge for the membership and
it's a quite a bit it looks like a big
market but when you go out and try to
ask for the money for the investors this
is not enough to whet their mouths for
this and the businessman I'm by training
I've is a scientist my P I've is a
professor here is a scientist so do our
customers do the customers and we
thought why don't we go and ask for
money from the government the government
NIH has a particular grant for the
startups which is called SBIR and you
can go and apply for the money so it was
going to be ours seed money and as I
said we worked on the membership models
so the first level of scientists twice
this system and then uses and shares
with the collaborators and the caliber
collaborator finds the system awesome
and then comes back and bi's and other
membership and we also looked at the
sales partners since I was in the
business for ten years I knew who would
be the sales partner because you need to
find somebody that everybody can trust
in the business but you don't want to
put a lot of money in your cells and
sales or marketing because you have
limited seed money so the best way if
you are the dealing with a niche market
is to go with an established company and
ask them whether they could be yourself
partner so the brain vision LLC was very
nice to accept being our sales partner I
me also this is also an important chart
so we we looked at our place in the
market so how we were completely very
we're standing when it was compared to
the others and also we worked on our
napkin model of financials of course I'm
not going to show all those eggs excel
sheets but there is a deep arithmetic
behind it you need to know what is your
operating costs how much money you are
paying on the servers and how much money
really is going to be enough to start
and take you up to the point that you
can make some revenue and also if you
ever went to do VCS they want to see
your accusation accusation model so
there are three models in the market
nowadays it is go big and get bought by
a giant in the business and you're going
to be on the headliners or another
another model is the startups the
startups can buy other startups to get
bigger and have better place in the
market or remain small and enjoy the
journey so you can be a niche company
you don't make million dollars but you
can make good enough money to keep you
going and then we we were fortunate
enough to point some users around you
can see it's some more work but most
importantly we couldn't really pass the
death valley of the startup so we stop
there because life took over we had to
do other stuff but we learned a lot from
this experience and I still use the
tower structure for my consulting job so
Tara structure is not that but doing
something else and 2010 and 2011 were a
little early to come up with this idea
because the time is evolving so fast
nowadays and the internet technologies
but in 2010 the cloud platforms were not
widely this it was started to be
discussed but it didn't trickle down to
the market that we were really targeting
the professor's were coming out of the
six sequester they really wanted to go
fast but at the same time they were so
afraid of being scooped so they didn't
really want to go and open up to this
unknown cloud environment and I think it
was partially my mistake that I didn't
understand the customer elbow and beyond
the story I I was so excited I mean I
was so still I'm varying angry because
there is this huge amount of data it
comes up comes out of their ear and it
is unrespectful for the participants and
patients that we don't really have any
results we visuals those release those
different data sets in different places
some of the date data data data sets it
on all some system huge old some systems
I don't know whether they will work or
not and you also find if you ever had I
mean do you any of anybody did you ever
miss a PhD student talking about the
thumb drive that they kept after they
graduated so I have some of those I
always saw me I still think that I could
fund they analyze my data so I I was
just so angry and I really wanted to do
something with that data it's also the
money i mean i'm trying to do a research
for example i'm trying to do a research
here in us and somebody else did the
same research 10 years ago maybe some we
are in Europe somewhere in Australia and
that data they didn't get to the point
that they can analyze they did that data
so the data is sitting there I'm trying
to do the ABCs of the same thing it is
time money everything involved but
unfortunately and then I didn't
understand the professors that they
really didn't want to come to that point
so I just took two part what they said
okay this is exciting but I didn't want
to hear did the demand part that they
didn't look tell me in those surveys the
other problem is that I mean neither of
us is good networkers so we don't
network with anybody we didn't even go
to the VCS or investors we were just so
attached to decided that we are going to
get the seed money from from the
government the networking is the key and
there are a lot of other models models
actually that we could look for one is
the crowdfunding crowdsourcing you all
do crowdsourcing you are I mean you have
get up icon and you involved with the
projects and stuff like that honestly
I'm doing one of those I think I really
it was a learning experience for me I'm
working for a company called rare
genomics there are almost 500 people
working for this company all over the
world none of them get and none of us
gets a penny but be more when putting
together the rare genetic disorders
together analyze the data try em leading
the cloud parts so we pull this date on
a cloud we have patience and China we
have patients in Australia and we work
nights and weekends
and I didn't know it could be so
fearfully and it could make people going
without the money so I think
crowdsourcing is a great idea nowadays
but I didn't know it back then and one
more thing that we never discussed we
never discussed about this Death Valley
of the startups the time that you don't
have any money coming in the in the
company but you need to get you need to
get going so that part is very important
and we didn't discuss that motional and
financially it is a very hard processing
you need to prepare yourself in the
beginning ok this is this was the part
of what I feel what I felt how we try to
deal with this problem how we try to
attack this problem but now forget about
everything and just remember this part
that I'm I'm just going to tell you
right now and take home use it
differently try to understand different
ways I also write these things on the on
the LinkedIn so you can go back find me
on linkedin read these things and then
you can say you're stupid eat it or
you're silly you can do it and we will
do it I'll be so happy to hear when when
you sucks it sucks it on this so first
thing first need and demand are two
different things they are not the same I
mean literally they could smell like the
same but you know you need to go have
water right but you can sit here until I
finish talking or go arts and maybe
couple days without having water the
moment that you really need to have that
border you feel like you're dying cannot
go any further it is the demand so when
you are getting into the business
you did a wait until that point that
your customers prospective customers
really really need that border patience
is the key when when it comes to this
demanded need balance and there are
three right things time place and
persons so sometimes you think that the
market is ready but it it might not be
ready everything might be saying that
okay everything is ready we're ready to
go but up that's a very thin line that
you need to realize and the place when
you are starting your business when you
have your alpha and beta users who are
going to be your advocate they are going
to tell people that you're wonderful
you're going to be close you get to see
their emotions closely you going to
exchange ideas feelings every day in
order to succeed and the persons persons
in the aspects of networking so go out
network find people I mean investors and
VC's want to give their money to the
people that they know and the
prospective customers are going to give
are going to buy the product from
somebody that they know to go out and
network but don't get me wrong so there
is networking and networking see I am
not telling that you go out smile
handshake with everybody that's not it
let's just do your study find right
people and then go meet them don't be
shy I have I have an advisor I
complained to all the time he became my
lifelong mentor and there was one thing
that he tells me all the time and
sometimes I feel like I'm patient not to
not to hear him not to listen
he tells me I'm gonna go out and meet
hundred people if I get help from one
person I'm going to be so lucky but
there is no point in the in the earth
sitting there and complaining that I'm
not getting in enough support because
nobody knows you there and also the
other other thing I want to say full
time versus part-time entrepreneurship I
mean startups are never part time you
cannot be part time in a start-up the
time time is very flocks you don't go
there at 8am and don't leave at 5pm you
will have a lot of time that you spend
there you will you cannot just have the
second job I understand me I didn't have
money we didn't have money so its luxury
to have money to run this company but
run any company but one thing I hear a
lot it was not very common maybe five
years ago is a full-timer this
designated fulton or tool timer for it
for a company to everybody else gypsum
one person works full time for the
company and I call it full-time driver
to the other chips in and that bridge
shipping and that person drives the
company and the other thing is of course
as I said money just sometimes you gotta
love ramen noodle so you will have a lot
of nights that you are having that so
one day I was at UNC a student was
talking and he was somewhere else he was
studying for GRE and then he didn't
leave this his little room so he ate
ramen not know though and he peed in the
cup no
that he hates you will have times like
that they louder ramen noodle again the
exit plan f call large or stay small oh
man so he could all become facebook or
google wouldn't be great making money
having a lot of stocks that's one way of
going the second way is getting bought
by companies like IBM or Microsoft these
are big companies it's wonderful so
you're going to be headliner of all the
news we all want to do that and all the
visas are going to be waiting for you to
give their money they will line up but
the third model is I think I like the
third model better is a small niche
company company model it will it will
give you enough money to be comfortable
and you will most likely get your
startup seed money from angels basically
friends and family but that's a very
stable way of going that and I guess
this is this is all I oh no this is not
all i can tell i just want to have some
fun with my talk and this is one thing
that i love i took it on on linkedin and
i realize i don't like this I cannot get
enough of this reading back and forth
this is not only for weak data it is the
same thing for the startups it's like
you don't know it nobody else knows it
and everybody claims that they are doing
it so pick your weapon attack it
wherever you go you have your tool
python you have different ways of
attacking it you can go crowdsourcing
you can you can do bootstrapping or you
can use every single penny that you have
to start your company so
my suggestion is go start your journey
and don't think about the destination
too much thank you if you have any
questions